david do you think joe biden has
any shot at passing that tax plan
so uh we talked about this a little bit
last week with nick majuli from
ritholtz wealth management i think that
there's two scenarios
without the senate it's just a hard no i
don't see
how on earth joe biden gets a tax reform
done
if he doesn't have the senate now with
the senate you've got a debate and
what's really important for many of you
to understand
is that joe biden although he may be to
your right
has put out a tax plan that is well to
the left of
many senate democrats who joe biden
would need to pass
tax reform there are many on the left
who are upset that joe biden has no
wealth tax in his tax plan
a wealth tax is not popular among senate
democrats if and until the senate
becomes
far more left than it is right now a
wealth tax has no chance of passing
whatsoever
so you're going to see uh if joe biden
gets the senate you'll see some
provisions that are likely to pass for
example
a return of the top marginal tax rate to
39.6 percent it was dropped to 36
percent or
maybe 37 36 37 under donald trump
that would almost certainly go back to
39.6 percent
it is seen by the democratic
establishment and
to be frank by some in the in the
republican establishment as something
that on paper looks nice we're raising
the top tax rate for the richest people
uh many people who are in that top tax
rate are not
um earning money through wages anyway so
they are not subject to that
you will almost certainly see that
uncapping
social security at 400 000
i think there's no way in hell that that
passes not because of joe biden but
because of
senate democrats um as you may know
right now you pay social security tax or
you and your employer
pay social security tax on the first
hundred and thirty thousand or so
dollars in earnings
and then social security tax goes to
zero once you get past that hundred and
thirty thousand whether you make
two hundred thousand a year a million 10
million a year
you pay zero once you get past that cap
joe biden's proposal is
at 400 000 plus the tax kicks back in
and it goes uncapped i think there is no
way in hell that senate democrats past
that
senate democrats are just too
conservative to see that happen
the increase in the capital gains tax
rate i think that that is
a 50 50 but that there are ways it gets
done
with some negotiation and then i think
that the stepped-up
basis provision that joe biden wants to
eliminate
is probably a long shot i won't explain
it all now because i've explained it in
a number of previous
videos will there be a new higher tax
bracket so
even if you raise the top tax bracket
from 37 to 39.6
as joe biden wants to do many
progressive economists and lawmakers say
well we need a
we need a higher tax bracket fine you
get into the highest tax bracket
at 500 000 a year in income but when you
get to
2 million a year in income then it
should go to 43
and when you get to 5 million a year in
income it should go to 48
and you know so on uh you you could have
that configured a number of different
ways
um i would be shocked if we saw that
again because the democratic party in
the senate
right now is well to the right
of where joe biden has run um
and uh that that's my thought on the
major provisions
of joe biden's tax plan if democrats
take the senate
i i i just don't see any path forward if
democrats don't take the senate if you
disagree with me let me know
i want to hear from you we've got a
great bonus show for you today remember
the number one way
to access the bonus show is to grab a
membership
at joinpacman.com do it i'll see you
then